oh come on I did not see you there I'm
feeling a little under the weather today
but I didn't want that to stop me from
making an intro to a very nice video for
you today we have Mikey Murphy on this
week my phone beeped god dammit
I'm just so popular we have Mikey Murphy
on not too deep today and what a lovely
human being he is I mean you can't see
it but oh my god sorry it's embarrassing
how popular I am you can't see it but
I'm smiling because I'm so happy that he
is on the podcast this week here are a
couple of my favorite moments from our
conversation and if you enjoy them or if
you don't enjoy them either way you
should go listen to the full podcast the
link is down below and we did a video on
Mikey's channel in which I waxed his
legs poof you can't see it but I have a
face of poof happening right now check
it out guys I'm here with Mikey Murphy
oh I'm so glad that you're here thank
you I got to meet you while we were
shooting dirty thirty which is one of
those weird experiences because I was
watching your videos and so when I met
you I felt like I already knew you and
it felt like I was just saying hi to a
friend that I hadn't seen in a while
yeah I had so much fun you're fantastic
in it thank you it's really gonna be so
sweet and I'm excited for it to come out
and for all of you to see it you only
recently moved to Los Angeles how long
ago
uh I believe it's like four months now
okay and is this your first experience
living on your own with a roommate okay
yeah what I like I went from like living
with my parents make you know they make
me dinner every night oh yeah
parents are great yeah what was one of
the weirdest things to get adjusted to
the fact that we went through like two
and a half months of like living in
filth because we had no idea what to do
how to clean like oh shoot you do have
to clean like every three days yeah
that's one of the like big wake-up calls
is you don't realize or appreciate I
think how much your parents clean your
house until they're not cleaning your
own house anymore
yeah no literally it was just like all
sudden were like we're done living like
this clean for three days literally like
took everything I mean and then put it
back and since then it's been like clean
did
you have to do the whole go to a store
and buy cleaning products and like what
do you even buy because even I have that
still now being 30 years old I have that
feeling when I go to Target I'm like how
do you clean things what do I need these
all of these solutions and these are all
I guess my mom came with me because she
originally flew out with me when I moved
to LA I had like four days with her and
she got all the cleaning supplies so
what I do is I just take pictures of it
and then I go to the so I get the same
colors I know that that's a good idea to
you vacuum have you purchased a vacuum
my grandparents got me a vacuum we're
like a little moving in gift that's very
sweet and we use that like three days a
week do you want come clean my house for
me it sounds like you guys know how to
do it more than me love cleaning for
some reason it's like I'm really
stressed and I just wanna like do
something mm-hmm vacuum everything clean
everything organize things that is very
rare it's amazing do you guys have any
like little nuances that you guys do
living together like are there any like
do you have like Taco Tuesday we're
really bad at cooking like the other day
I tried cooking and yeah a lot of the
questions for you on Twitter are like
have you made anything that you can eat
lately yeah I yeah I made a pizza I was
taking it out of the oven uh-huh
and my finger got burned on the back of
the stove like a drawer yeah I like that
burn now well that's kind of cool it's
gonna pull a cart burn from cooking
pizza and I have a scar here from like
cheese grating like oh look at your like
a domestic god yeah I think like
something that we have as tradition is
like on Mondays we clean like the fret
that no one joins that's like on Mondays
we clean we don't we don't cook much so
we just like we go out yeah we eat
things that we have in the house cuz
like we get a few snacks well that's I
think an interesting things to learn too
as an adult is that you can go out and
order food from places because I don't
know kind of like high school you went
to but I went to a high school where
everyone ate lunch in the high school no
one like left being an adult and
realizing like oh I can go out and get
food for dinner
anywhere I want and you can just do it
you want you just do it and they can do
it again um there's a lot of Twitter
questions for you yeah I'm excited okay
so let's get right into them um there
some of them might change your life
you could bring only one travel thing to
travel around the world
with what would it be yes I bring my
zantac okay heartburn and I know
bhrastika here actually like a 60 year
old man yeah on set Mike you always had
an ailment thing happening video that we
were like sick
what I was also eating like like the
makeup artist like can you eat all of
these fire tamales or whatever those
things are called yeah eat a whole box
and I was like okay the entire thing I
was crying and then my heart was burning
and go told you to do that and then
there really eat as many of those
gushers as you can all like okay and is
your really society don't and neither
peer pressure that might have happened
here my Dolly's on set up thirty thirty
dared me I was like okay I could be a
vegetable I'm gonna go with my favorite
vegetable okay
celery who are you one arm right no
because I always associate vegetables
celery the one you're a flan I don't so
we're just so bad and then that one's
like alright